Alzheimer's disease
seriously both amyloid plaques and tau
pathology static findings suggest that
amyloid is causally involved in a deep
opportunities am I right web sites are
formed by the activity of the base and
gamma secretase therefore inhibitors of
those enzymes have been developed and
dist in the clinic however almost all of
the clinical trials with amyloid
lowering agent so far failed to shall
continue benefits despite showing the
reduced target engagement cuando
Edison's pharmacology is basically an
advanced computer model of neuronal
circuits but action potential dynamics
are simulated our Alzheimer platform in
the top left corner consists of a
cortical network with excitatory and
inhibitory neurons it appropriate
voltage in ragged gated ion channels and
more than thirsty CNS related targets
the system has been calibrated by
learning circle clinical trials with us
telco mistress inhibitors and serotonin
six antagonists and then correlating the
model outcome with the report for
clinical trials in addition we have been
able to blindly and correctly predict
and expect a clinical outcome for a
novel target in systemic Alzheimer's
disease first we test the impact of the
serotonin transporter genotype on the
top rights figure a covenant variant
that determines the density of
transporters and therefore that basil
serotonin activation level using imaging
data with the serotonin for specific
rate accessory in the militant
unmedicated healthy volunteers we derive
the appropriate her love life of
serotonin and shout that a genotype can
lead to a three to four point difference
in a clinical scale of Alaska we then
implemented disorder physiology of a
beta in model on the left side shorter a
better forms 12 14 10 to strengthen the
automatic transmission as loud doses
which has a negative effect at higher
doses the lumber a beta forms 12 42
monotonically decreasing with
motivational transmission in addition
both peptides form 7 negative impact on
alpha7 nicotinic receptors
mission but the model was first tested
to make sure it can reproduce to
clinical data sets on the bottom left
one on the interaction between a better
loads and scopolamine in minimal
quantities impairment subjects with
subjects having higher a bed a lot being
more sensitive to scopolamine the other
observation is a lack of apoe effect on
the context trajectory over time once
the diagnosis of AD has been confirmed
guilty of observed changes in a beta 40
in a bit of 42 biomarkers should base
innovation in the middle of the toaster
monomers vaccination and gamma secretase
inhibition are done implemented in a
virtual patient trial in mild to
moderate a deep basement followed over
seventy eight weeks for ad patients with
high baseline a beta base inhibition and
gamma secretase in addition shall only
an improvement a slumber trial duration
while monomers vaccination has about a
one-point course possible improvement
over the whole trial duration most
importantly for a these subjects with a
loud baseline a beta load the model
suggests that base inhibition and gamma
figured this inhibition actually worsham
clinical hard [ __ ] this underscores the
complex interaction between a beta and
cognition and might explain the failed
clinical trials the simulations provide
an explanation why almost all amyloid
lowering interventions work fine in
technical sunshine animals and those are
designed to have artificially high
levels of beta amyloid to accelerate the
pathology it would love to check these
model predictions to existing clinical
data from the Solano's the map and the
very basis that trials this would allow
us to improve the model and provide
guidance for other terrific
interventions it is extremely important
to confirm or refute these outcomes as a
model curve they would predict that now
during beta amyloid in 30 disease states
with low Amelia clothes that actually
worsen function outcomes
conclusion q SP is a new technology for
translation of the clinical data into
the clinical setting that might help
improve clinical trial design